sorry everyone I think my memory
the help committee will resume its
sitting on the reauthorization of the
Elementary and Secondary Education Act
bill now I know that Senator Warren has
to be in the chair at five o'clock and I
was next recognizing senator Baldwin for
an amendment however if you want to
yield to Senator Warren I would
recognize senator Warren for that
purpose Thank You mr. chairman and thank
you senator Baldwin I want to offer an
amendment that is a charter school
accountability amendment it's a
technical change it is not a policy
change the whole point is to clarify
about accountability for charter schools
the it's the original intent I think of
the statute it is administration policy
and the point is just simply to say
charter schools are public schools they
have to meet the same standards of
accountability as other public schools
and the language here is to try to
clarify that I want to stress the
amendment is not a change in any policy
but there seems to be some confusion
about the language I see no point in
adding to the confusion the whole point
is to make sure that this is clear so i
am happy to offer my amendment and to
withdraw my amendment to work with the
chair and with stakeholders to reflect
this policy be sure we have the right
language that reflects that everybody
plays for the same rules charter schools
and other public schools so with that
mr. Chairman I both offer and withdrawal
I thank the senator for offering this
and for bringing this to our attention
I'm our bill not only ensures that
charter schools are subject to ESEA s
accountability provisions but also
targets federal charter school funding
to high-performing schools again I want
the senator know that I will work with
her our staff to craft language that
achieves azhar achieves our shared
objective of having all charter schools
be subject to public school account
ability and but also allows authorizers
to shut down low quality charters in a
timely basis according to state charter
school laws so look forward to working
with you on that thank you very much mr.
chairman thank you for your leadership
on all issues and thank you very much
for working on this Thank You senator
senator Warren thank you and thank you
senator Baldwin the that we've agreed
that we could go back to senator Baldwin
then you can bring up your amendment now
senator ball Thank You mr. chairman I
want to begin by thanking you and the
ranking member for the hard work and
attention that's gone into getting us to
where we are today and I wanted to
mention an element that I think bring an
element of the amendment that I'm
bringing up that rings through between
both the bill before us as well as the
substitute that was offered earlier
today by ranking member Alexander and
that is the emphasis on both preparation
for post-secondary education as well as
Career and Technical Education and
preparedness and just in case I haven't
formally done that yet i would call up
baldwin title one amendment number one
both of the both the underlying bill
before us today and the substitute have
appropriately focused on college and
career preparedness but we've heard
during the course of our debate some
substantial difference of opinion on the
scope of what should be required of
states and local education agencies with
regard to data collection and analysis
and reporting etc but I think there's
agreement that as we put together report
cards that are available to the public
and student
then we want to be able to measure both
college readiness and career readiness
and that's essentially what the
amendment that I'm presenting to
everyone today does my amendment builds
on our commitment to making students
career ready by matching the
requirements currently in the bill to
provide opportunities to learn about
post-secondary coursework in a nutshell
were providing students and parents with
a snapshot of what Career and Technology
education programs are available at
their local schools many states have
already recognized the importance of
reporting on Career and Technology
education and have adopted data
requirements as part of their Department
of Education approved ESEA flexibility
waivers and I would exempt elective the
states of Maryland North Carolina
Florida Georgia Kentucky New Mexico
Oklahoma and Virginia in which states
already asked school districts for data
on things like industry certification
attainment at minimum these type of
measures should be allowed as part of a
state accountability systems and schools
at part of the school and equity report
cards to reflect a more complete picture
of career readiness I'll quickly note
that my home state of Wisconsin is full
of examples of successful career and
technical education training programs
and our secondary schools have engaged
in a unique collaboration a set of
collaborations of partnerships with
technical colleges and businesses
throughout the state to provide our
students with hands-on learning and
career preparedness I am going to go
with the the right to close and if there
is some consternation or questions about
this I have lots of more examples and
details to throw your way but I would
urge that given this bipartisan
commitment that we hold our schools
accountable for both post-secondary
preparedness as well as career
preparedness that we have our report
cards and measurements reflect that mr.
chairman yes senator Enzi of all of the
mandatory things that are in the bill I
kind of like this one the best I just
don't like any of them being in the bill
it's official i'm really considering
doing a title for the bill that would be
pretty good suggestions at all school
board members out pay attention to
because well the coffee cup i'm using a
skillsusa i promote that a lot the kids
that participate in that really have
some phenomenal talents they've actually
learned something that they can make a
living at and some of those people are
ones that we are absolutely going to be
needing I found a book it's called the
hidden America the subtitle on it is
coal miners to cowboys the hidden people
that get up every morning get their
hands dirty so that you have what you
need and it goes into a whole bunch of
those different career perfections and
they're they're extremely important at
the pre and one of the reasons we
changed the title on the Republican
substitute was to place a little more
emphasis on career and we really ought
to be doing that in America right now
we're trying to do is make them
embarrassed if they want to have a
technical career I got to visit sweden
last year and I was kind of fascinated
that when you graduate from high school
there that you go to tech school and you
get a career and then you can go to
college and of course a lot of them take
their career after they have the career
and they don't go on to college but it's
something they wanted to do there happy
to do and it doesn't have the same
stigma that we sometimes place on it in
America but this is one more reporting
requirement and I assume that where it's
placed that will also have to
disaggregate it according to the other
150 things that they're required to
report and again I think it's a great
suggestion but I hate the place that's
as one of the required things that all
the schools have to do I would hope that
they would pick that up on their own
make that the number one requirement for
reporting on their kids and I can't see
how we do this without disaggregating so
that ought to be a part of it too which
one send a senator I read as you
recommended that book to me some time
ago the hidden America is a great book
that's the second good book you know I
got a third one today now I get it you
read good books but let me just I
understand this this is just part this
would be adding a part to the state
accountability systems and the school
and equity report cards to basically
give a percentage of students that earn
an industry recognized credential in
addition to a high school diploma least
that's what is correct
mr. chairman could I see what I find to
me could I ask the author a question
sure I'm refreshing myself with the
requirements under the Perkins grants
and Perkins requires participating
educational institutions to report I
think everything that you're asking for
so I guess my question is is this not
duplicate avow already require under
Perkins can you repeat the last part of
your question is is this not a duplicate
if requirement that's already existing
under the Perkins grant program the in
this available for us the equity report
cards and the school report cards are
made public and the reporting
requirements under the Perkins Career
and Technical Education Act are not a
part of that reporting that is supposed
to help parents and students understand
the capacity of their le A's to provide
this type of preparation and you know
what would the burden not fall on since
and I'm I don't know enough about this
mr. chairman to really ask specific
questions but the only thing I'm
attempting to do is not to duplicate
something that we already asked for and
in the Perkins grant requirements there
is a section that requires what I think
is included in this amendment all to be
provided so I would ask the author is
there a way for us to say okay as long
as you've provided that through Perkins
then it's up to us the federal
government since we're the recipient of
this information to then disseminate
that information rather than to require
a whole new section which means most
institutions will do this twice adopting
my amendment will achieve your end yes
recording twice what would require
reporting twice the site would aggregate
would align it in our report card and
our school report card on our equity
report card it would put it pull it all
together which is what we need to do Kim
can I ask a friendly suggestion could
could you withdraw the amendment until
we've had an opportunity just to verify
that and I'll be your biggest fan but I
still believe that we're duplicating the
same requirements of reporting I don't
think that's your intent but I'm not
convinced that this if passed requires
an institution to file a single status
of this information I would be happy to
work with you further on this and again
my intent is that the two report cards
that are called for in the underlying
bill that we're amending right now focus
not only on preparedness for
post-secondary education but also have
that emphasis on Career and Technical
Education by including this data in in
those report cards and again I wanted to
emphasize that this was in my mind a
goal of both the bill that were marking
up right now as well as the Republicans
substitute so I do hope we can come
together and work this through I would
agree with you and I'm not asking for
this to be pushed over to mark up i
would like to resolve it before we move
this bill out of the committee well i
just say to both i'd say that obviously
we're not voting on this now anyway we
have to put the boats off till tomorrow
so might I suggest that your staffs get
together and see what you can do to work
we head out to this I'd not certain I
understand all of it I was just
understood was trying to align what ESEA
is doing and what Perkins is doing try
to get them on the same kind of
wavelength that's what items told if I
could read and understand at a faster
pace I might be able to answer the
question right well what you guys work
it okay we will
we'll work that out so we'll set that
amendment aside then until tomorrow mr.
chairman yes sir I know that we have
unanimous consent to continue but it
looks to me like with you know three on
your side and two on my side that we've
evidently decided that nobody has to
hear the debate that it won't make any
difference that it'll continue on the
same party line process that we've been
through so far and if that's going to
continue to be the case we can go ahead
but if it's not we ought to really have
some people here hearing the arguments
on these amendments do we have anybody
in the back sometimes we have senators
back to you're making phone calls and
stuff don't think so and I guess senator
Alexander is on his way I'm told there
were several other meetings that were
called for about four o'clock and I came
down you know including the boat so well
do you have an amendment and when you
have the last vote in the day at
four-thirty su harder yeah corral people
chairman yes sir he's chairman I'll I'll
go ahead and call an amendment up if
that's ok with the chair if you'd like
yes it would be amendment number two
title to number one just titled to
number one Idol new number and I will be
brief because I think this is going to
be fairly simple for people to
understand as in 2011 this committee did
the right thing by removing an
antiquated hold harmless which served
allocate the title to a funds based upon
state population since the mid-1990s
this one steps towards addressing
population and poverty and states
particularly in those with high levels
of growth since a decade ago this
amendment tries to further assist those
states with high growth and high poverty
by revising the state allocation formula
to bring it into parity with how funds
are sub granted to school districts
within a state now states receive an
allotment based upon thirty five percent
population in 65
and poverty in their states Alexander
bill uses a split of twenty percent
population in eighty percent poverty no
place in a higher priority on focusing
on poverty for federal funds this
approach is also consistent with our
senator Alexander and Harkins bills sub
grant funds to school districts again by
using a 2080 split the only outlier is
how the Harkin bill alots payments to
States by retaining the antiquated what
I think is antiquated 6035 65 this
amendment would simply change the amount
to an 2080 split which would be used for
state and district formulas and where
the current hurricane bill is only for
district subgrant formulas of the
purpose of this amendment is simple to
target poverty as best we can with the
limited amount of federal funds and we
do that through adjusting the formula
distribution I would urge my colleagues
to support this it very much embraces
the spirit of what I've heard in this
debate that we want to focus on kids in
poverty we want to focus on
low-performing schools this gets a part
of it by providing more money because of
poverty than it does because of
population
I thank Senator burr formula fights
they're always a problem and again it is
that it's been sort of the standard
operation of at least this committee
even before me I think to have formula
changes for the floor not in committee
according to crs 19 states would lose
money under this change even a small
loss could have a large impact for
States given sequestration another
financial issue states are facing
actually point out that we do give more
weight to poverty in our le a
distribution formula and that should
address some concerns I would assume
that this would also be revisited on the
floor I say to my friend from North
Carolina these are all these these old
formula fights
and when you look at all the states that
are losing and some obviously some
states gained but states lose so I I
would I would I would hope that this
would be the kind of thing that would be
put off till the to the floor and so
because it affects every senator doesn't
just affect people on this committee
affects all senators and so I would I
would I would hope that we wouldn't put
senators under his right obviously to
have a vote on this if he wants some
committee that's perfectly within his
rights I'd hoped that we would put it
off to the floor mr. Chairman I actually
thought this was going to be a
non-contentious amendment I think
everybody's focused on that the limited
resources we have should go after the
most at risk and poverty is probably the
way that we define that the most in
education and yeah unfortunately 19
states are losers when you change to an
80 2080 split the question is is the
money going to follow the most at-risk
students or are we going to continue to
provide money to states that don't have
as serious a problem or challenge as
other states and I think in the spirit
of what we've debated today and will
debate tomorrow and talked about in the
education we would be enthusiastic to
put more weight on poverty than we do on
population population suggest that there
are more resources at the state and
local level to address the funding of K
through 12 poverty would suggest that
there's less resources and it's a it is
the targeted group that we're after so I
think it would be a very appropriate
thing for the committee and if I
realized we'll have to wait till
tomorrow but I did want to start the
debate today and everybody would have an
opportunity to not only see how their
state fair but they ask themselves deep
down is this more about how many kids
are in poverty is it more about the
population of each state
well I have to look at this I mean I'm
surprised that my friend from North
Carolina would think this would be
non-contentious when Iowa would lose six
point two percent of his title to money
well i would i would suggest to the to
the to the chairman clearly he doesn't
have the level of poverty in Iowa that
an Alabama does or that a North Carolina
does or the other 31 states that
actually benefit and this are actually
positively treated and this is for title
to money not title one months that's
correct idle to tidal took teacher
teacher preparation stuff money well I
still I still think that you know 19
states would lose I I might want to work
with the senator on this I I don't know
how long the formulas been in there like
it's been in there I got to find out was
it changed under No Child Left Behind I
don't know but I'd like to get some more
information on well mr. chairman as I
pointed out in my remarks for since the
mid-1990s this was calculated one
hundred percent on poverty and then we
moved to a split of poverty excuse me on
population then we moved to a split of
population in poverty this is again
moving to wait more on poverty than it
is on population I would say for my
colleagues this is strongly endorsed by
the NEA
so right before no child left behind him
it was a hundred percent on on
population aspect miss Chairman I think
we changed at some point after the the
implementation of No Child Left Behind
but the current formula you have
maintained in your bill which is 3565
thirty-five percent population
sixty-five percent poverty and my
suggestion is we go to twenty percent
population and eighty percent poverty
but I think it at least I'm told it came
with NCLB I don't know what it was
before in clv that's what I don't my
understanding there was one hundred
percent population is all population
that's my understanding since the
mid-1990s so that was that was a big
change then then obviously well I you
know just while I sympathize with the
senator I'd have to know more about what
the impact would be on this in terms of
of the impact on all these states and
since we don't have a corner to vote
anyway we'll be voting on it tomorrow
I'd like to take a little stronger look
at this before we get to it tomorrow may
be happy to do that and where we can we
can debate it more when we've got more
members here I thank the chair I take a
look at why I appreciate the senator and
I'll dig into it a little bit more I ask
all other senators who are here and
their staffs take a look at that's your
own States and see what see what this
would mean again I don't I think the
senator is right we don't want to be
selfish but I just want to know what the
impact is when you change that in terms
of poverty and population I just don't
know the envelope again the net impact
is we allocate the same amount of money
it's just we later heavier towards
poverty in which is I think the right
the moral thing to do well also I don't
know see I have a problem with title to
money anyway always has for a long time
on how that money is being spent anyway
the determine can alleviate that by just
throwing all of it in a pot where
schools can access it regardless of
everybody solvation amendment so okay so
is there any more debate on that
amendment I didn't mean to cut anybody
off so we'll pick it up again tomorrow
when we come back tomorrow and we'll be
stacking votes for tomorrow morning
including voice votes of C then senator
murray you have an amendment senator
murray
thank you very much mr. chairman punch
it harder you think you're weird to
muscles do that mr. Chairman I will call
up my amendment number 22 title one and
would like to offer that right now and
this is an amendment that has to do with
increasing equity and school sports to
help make sure that girls receive the
same opportunities boys to participate
in school sports going to start by
saying us all of us know 40 years ago
Congress passed title nine it really
paved the way for educational equity for
girls and women including in school
athletics this committee actually held a
hearing last year on this and we clearly
heard that there is certainly a lot more
work that needs to be done to fix the
underlying issue girls across the
country are still not getting equal
opportunities to play sports and they
are often assigned inferior facilities
or game times and are provided with
fewer resources and support than their
male peers today our laws require
colleges to report data on gender equity
and sports programs but we don't require
the same for elementary and secondary
schools so what my amendment does is it
requires schools to report the types of
information that college is due regard
regarding equality of access of access
to funding for and quality of organized
sports programs for girls by making this
information public mr. chairman my
amendment will really shine a light on
the lack of opportunity for girls to
participate in these important programs
which is a critical first step to
solving the problem you know years of
research have shown that girls who have
have opportunities to play sports have a
lower risk of obesity later in life they
have lower early pregnancy rates they
have lower incidence of depression and
they have a more positive body body body
image girls who participate in these
sports programs are also more likely to
be successful in school and in their
careers and the same research shows that
female athletes are more likely to
graduate from high school have better
grades and score higher on standardized
tests so this chairman as we heard in
our here
the evidence is really clear and I think
we can all agree that those are positive
outcomes that we all should be working
towards this amendment has received the
backing of business and women's groups
across the country including the
American Association of University Women
the National Council of women's
organizations and the u.s. women's
Chamber of Commerce now mr. chairman
I've been sitting at this hearing all
day as you have and I know what my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle are going to say they haven't been
very shy here today about panning any
data reporting that we're asking for in
this hill bill but here's what I think I
think that information is really
powerful I was here as you were mr.
chairman back in 2001 when we wrote the
No Child Left Behind bill and because of
the data requirements of that
legislation for the first time at a
national level we were really able to
see the achievement gaps that exist in
this country and I have talked to many
people over the last 12 years about
where we need to go on education policy
and what we need to change and I've
heard over and over again that we need
to keep that data reporting in place
because it is a powerful tool now my
colleagues on the other side of the keep
have been asking today why the federal
government needs to know the information
that we've been asking for in this bill
not just in my amendment that I'm
offering but it across the spectrum now
they may feel differently they have a
right to do that but as i said earlier
with my earlier amendment I believe that
ensuring the educational success of all
children in this country is a task that
we have to focus on and the information
that we're asking for that's provided
under this bill is useful on a lot of
different levels from the schoolhouse to
the Statehouse too yep here at the
federal level this data helps us ensure
equity which is at the heart of the bill
that we're talking about today without
the information that we're calling for
in this legislation we struggle to know
where the inequities are taking place
and we don't know we importantly do not
know where promising practices lie that
can be shared across the country and
we're more support with limited
resources today might be beneficial
this is also vital information that can
be used when it's public by advocates
and chant champions for children around
our country they are the watchdog's that
make sure that our children get the
resources and support they need to
succeed and finally I would say public
information is vital for parents you
know I believe as I said parents that
are armed with good information can be
powerful and they can be influential I
know that was the case for me when I
first got involved in politics many
years ago around the issue of education
when our state legislature was trying to
cut funding for a preschool program it's
what put me on the path to where I am
today information is useful it's
powerful and it's needed so I believe
the information that we're asking for
both in the amendment that I'm offering
and in the bill that we've been
discussing all day will give parents it
will give policymakers and it will give
stakeholders the tools they need to
identify problems and the information so
we can target our resources successfully
so mr. chairman that last comment was
about all of the reporting that we're
asking for in this and why I think it's
important but I think in offering this
amendment right now on the information
in terms of equity ins in school sports
this is especially important for all of
us I mean I have watched the success of
title nine and I know that the more
resources that we can make sure are
being played equitably across sports for
our younger goals will make a difference
in their lifetime achievement so I urge
the adoption of this amendment and ask
for a committee to consider it mr.
chairman senator Alexander I mean I
obviously don't doubt the sincerity of
the senator and I'm a supporter of title
nine but I'm sitting here thinking you
know the girls softball coach in Milan
Tennessee is going to be spending more
time filling out forms and coaching the
girls I mean
remember this that this sounds innocuous
it sounds well-meaning but number one we
already have title nine it's enforced on
high schools so they they already have
their own title nine enforcement
apparatus and then second my math is
right this would require about 10 to 12
different reports of disaggregated and
cross tabulated reports / sport there
are a hundred thousand schools so that's
a million new pieces of information per
sport let's say they're ten sports in a
school that's ten million new piece of
reported information it includes the
season the team competed whether the
team participated in postseason
competition now that means you know in
Greene County that means the mosheim
McDonald middle school basketball game
you know did they so we have to fill all
that out total number of competitions
scheduled total expenditure from all
sources I guess that's the Pepsi money
and the you know the bake sale all of
that total number of coaches trainers
medical personnel gender employment
status in their duties that's probably
the the nurse who's taking time off to
go down and help with the elementary
school game I mean mr. chairman there
are any number of well-intentioned ideas
we could happen here the United States
Senate but we've got to remember we're
imposing these on 100,000 public schools
across the country whose main focus
ought to be using their good judgment to
help children they're presented with
learn what they need to know and be able
to do so so it's hard for me to imagine
imposing million
of new requirements here on schools
including information about whether the
team participated in postseason
competition who's going to read this hmm
I think maybe we need a field trip from
this committee down the US Department of
Education and find out where they store
all this stuff and and who actually is
reading it and who here is doing
anything about it these are things that
people should be doing in their own
communities and especially since we
already have title not nine and it's
full panoply of enforcement activities
it's hard to see for me to see how this
is anything more than a huge burden on
on local schools Oh mr. chairman senator
mark I have to respond first of all
schools know what they're spending on
this they know how much money they're
spending we're just asking for it to be
made public so that parents know when
they feel something isn't right they
have access to some information and can
help make their case I think that you
know as a mom I just would say yeah I'm
going to go ask about the information if
I feel that my daughter sports during an
inferior facility which we know that
that exists today if I know that the
field that my daughter is playing on has
no lights at night but the Mansfield is
well-lit we're just asking for public
information of something that schools
already know and you know I just have to
say that the the data is very clear
about this success for women who are
able to participate in sports I think
that's something any of us wants for our
daughters and four women in this country
and and I really hope that our
colleagues will see the light and
recognize that you know it's a day when
we ought to encourage this we ought to
make it a reporting requirement of
information that schools already have so
that the public knows and we can make
good decisions in this country and
expand the ability for women to have
access to fair and equal sports
mr. chairman senator Enzi I think
titanides made a tremendous difference
and it affected my daughter's tunnel
that affected me there was a girl's
organization that invited me to join
after this law passed but that had never
had any any men in it before that's
beside the point on this and while I
don't think this ranks as high as the
skills bill the certified career school
amendment I'd be happy to put this on my
title 12 of pretty good suggestions for
school boards but would not want to put
it in laws another another requirement
if the school board's think this could
make a difference or the parents the
parents thought I have access to you
know all these pretty good suggestions
as well in fact if we could make them
read all the pretty good suggestions
they might insist on a few more of them
but to just place all of these in the
lap of people all in one fell swoop I
think we've just inundated the education
system this one amendment will be a
tremendous tremendous burden on schools
I like kind of like the idea I'm not
sure how we would then legislate i know
that in wyoming the boys sports football
in the girls sports volleyball we don't
have men's volleyball and it's probably
because of title nine so we have equal
sports but I know it doesn't cost nearly
as much to put up volleyball nets and
provide the equipment for volleyball as
it does for football I'm bettin that the
differences just having safe helmets as
as much of a cost as providing for a
person to play volleyball so then do we
legislate that they have to spend and he
call them out on the volleyball as they
do on football that would be one use of
this information I have no idea where
some of this would go with the
requirements for you know what what
spent I'm pretty sure people would be
interested in what's been because I
don't think I've ever seen the
tabulation of what it costs any of the
high schools in Wyoming play football
or volleyball or soccer or any of the
things they've never broken that out
made it public it might be really
interesting so therefore I'd put it in
my list pretty good suggestions but I
certainly wouldn't vote to put it in the
bill mr. chairman Shin Amara let me just
say one thing I can alleviate the
Senators concern about the time
requirement because some states have
implemented a similar requirement and
administrators say that it takes about
two hours maybe a bit longer if they
have a high number of sports to compile
this data we're not talking about a
burdensome requirement we're talking
about the ability for communities across
the country to be able to assess the
equity that their daughters who are in
high school and elementary school can
make sure that they get fields that are
well-lit make sure that they get good
equipment make sure that they have
access and I think that's something that
our country ought to do and focus on and
I think it will be a priority mr.
chairman just I can't pass on the
comment done i mounted amount of time if
the government's estimating how much
time it takes to fill out a report I've
got some problems with it because I'm on
the Finance Committee and we're looking
at all the tax issues and all the forms
say how long it takes to fill them out
and I haven't run into anybody yet the
control them out the amount of time that
they say so if it's two hours to do this
for each sport and each gender we're
talking about some time here I I just
might just add that on this eye on this
intention that well you fill out all
those reports they go into the
department who reads them there there's
another benefit to the local
jurisdictions and local schools from
filling out these reports a lot of times
it prods them into thinking about what
they are doing and how they are
fulfilling the requirements of a certain
provision of law like title nine so I
think there's a there's an inherent
benefit for schools and when they fill
out some kind of report like this to
think about these kind of inequities
that Senator Murray has talked about
they might want to get it in my CTA we
thought
we were doing all right on title nine
but you know I guess we really aren't
when you think about it when you think
about all the other things that we put
into something else maybe we have to
rethink a little bit what we're doing
here so it's not just about who reads
those reports I think there's an
inherent benefit of just having schools
do that exercise and to take a look at
at what they're doing so i guess i don't
i don't see that this is over overly
onerous in any way and i think it would
be a good exercise for them to go
through as a matter of fact that just
might be one I always let them I we're
not going to be all voting on these
amendments I don't know if sarah marie
wants to add anything right now Thank
You chairman again as I said information
is powerful lack of information is
extremely powerless and I think that
this kind of information is good for our
country and I urge the adoption of the
amendment will set the amendment aside I
understand that you said was ok for good
a movie sure we're just talking about
senator Murphy has a amendment is Thank
You mr. chairman i believe it's murphy
number one to be called up at this point
mr. Chairman I like to thank my
colleagues for all the kindness that
they've shown the families of Sandy Hook
who have been here on Capitol Hill for
more time than you would think grieving
families would they're here actually
back again this week trying to put back
some of the pieces of the gun reform
agenda but this is still very much a
community in crisis in part because all
of the children in sandy hook elementary
school are now going to school in
another town and there is a recognition
that sandy hook elementary school cannot
open again that the municipality is
going to have to build a new school one
of the programs that's been of great
benefits to Sandy Hook has been the
department of education projects serve
program this is a program that provides
grants for schools to help recover from
a violent or train
event they can be used for funding
mental health services teacher and staff
over time temporary security amongst
other things and secretary Duncan was
just in Connecticut a couple weeks ago
announcing that we had received a fairly
generous grant from the serv program
that's going to help us try to work
through the ongoing crisis that comes
when you lose twenty six and
seven-year-olds one of the things that
is ineligible for funding under the
served program is school construction
and this amendment is very simple it
essentially lifts that prohibition on
serve program dollars being used for
school construction and allows for in
these very limited instances where you
have such an awful and grievous violent
incident in which you can't go back to
school in the very place of the tragedy
occurred that served dollars should be
eligible for the reconstruction of that
facility this is a small town they do
not have the resources available
themselves to rebuild the school now the
state is going to help but there's still
a gap there and so this would be of
great assistance to the community of
Sandy Hook into these families to have
at least the eligibility of served
dollars to be used here this is not
opening up the federal government to
getting into the business of funding
school construction I don't support that
I don't think this committee does this
is simply saying in those very unique
instances where there has been such an
awful incident at the school it cannot
the students cannot go back to the
school that we are going to help in some
small way or at least allow this account
to help at no more than a 50-percent
cost share now the reality is is that
there's you know I think not more than
ten million dollars or so in this
account at any one given time so it's
not likely that even if the school
district made a successful application
for school construction funds that it
would amount to more than a small
percentage of the overall costs but in a
small town like Sandy Hook this would
certainly help I appreciate the chairman
for his help in the committee's help in
putting this amendment together and I'd
hoped
we could get the support of the
committee when time comes to vote mr.
chairman yes sir cinderella's may ask
what is the recommended what's the
appropriation level recommended for this
this this is simply a change in the
authorization of the accounts of the
account right now does not authorize
funding to be used for school
construction so there's no appropriation
in this but typically typically you have
a an amount for the appropriation that
you're thinking of it we're simply
changing the parameters of the program
it is this right now the program does
not allow well it's a new program and
typically you'd say here's a new program
and it's a two-million-dollar program
and then the Appropriations Committee
would appropriate whatever it could I
don't believe this is a new program this
is the project serve program is an
existing program that right now provides
programmatic support to schools in
crisis and what we're doing here is
allowing for this existing account which
right now funds programming to also
allow for school construction to be
eligible for an existing account so
we're not changing we're not creating a
new account we're not appropriating and
money we're just simply taking an
existing crisis intervention fund and
changing the criteria of what it can
fund except your intent I would consider
it a new program let me what is a
violent or traumatic crisis would that
include our Akane I don't know the
there's I think a very you know well
defined set of practice at the
department of education as to what
project serve is used to fund I just
know that it funds episodes like the one
we saw at Sandy Hook and so this
amendment doesn't seek to change the
type of incidents that project sir
there's an existing definition of
violent or traumatic crisis in the
Department of Education I that right
sure
yeah so here's the definition so the
definition is shootings or other serious
violent incidents in schools suicides of
students faculty or staff hate crimes
committed against students or homicides
of students faculty or staff or staff so
projects in current law that's right so
that's what project serve is used for
today so it's violent or traumatic
episodes at schools that disrupts the
teaching and learning environment and
again so this the account today is
primarily used to facilitate programming
for social workers and other potential
security changes there are going to be
very limited instances where this
violent episode is so bad that you need
to construct a new school I mean they're
just a handful of places where that's
ever ever happened and so in those
limited instances we're just asking that
the dollars be available for school
construction it would still be up to the
Department of Education whether they
granted that request they'd have to
weigh a request for school construction
dollars against other programmatic
requests or just asking that it be
eligible yeah as I'm trying to catch up
with this it looks like the current law
says it's a crisis management plan and
it seems to me you're turning that into
construction to build to build a new
school it would that kind of thing would
seem to me would come under the FEMA or
under the disaster provisions that we
that we have we have provisions in the
law for for emergencies and disasters
declared by the president that that that
have construction of public buildings
that are that are damaged this seems to
me a pretty big jump from a crisis
management plan for violent or traumatic
crisis to building to building fifty
percent of the cost of a new school well
well senator Alexander FEMA is set up to
respond to natural disasters and
traditionally a school shooting does not
fall under FEMA's jurisdiction it falls
under
the Department of Education jurisdiction
there is precedent for serve dollars to
be used to fund very small repairs in
schools to respond to some of these
crises but right now you would have to
radically change the authorization
statutes for FEMA to allow those dollars
to be used to respond to a school
shooting again we're not opening a big
door here I mean you know we can count
on you know a handful of fingers on one
hand the number of episodes that were so
awful and traumatic that you couldn't
reopen the school I think Columbine and
Sandy Hook maybe it but well the
tornadoes in pursuit every year terrible
problems in Oklahoma Tennessee other
places I mean why isn't that a violent
or Trump traumatic Christ well but again
for what I'm for violent episodes such
as a school shooting FEMA dollars are
not eligible for those reconstruction
costs because there's not the only
school shooting a school shooting is not
a natural disaster but you you listed a
whole series of things that might well
but none of them would be covered under
FEMA right so I'm talking about that but
if I remember right but it might not
correct that it's a crisis management
plan for how you deal with those things
that you listed including suicides
school shootings corral and you're
suggesting an amendment to change that
to build a building in response to that
in the in the in the incredibly limited
and isolated instances in which you
can't return to that building and again
all I'm not suggesting you turn this
account into a school construction
account I'm just simply trying to
recognize the fact that there are going
to be a handful of instances in which a
proper response to a school shooting is
going to include both putting social
workers on the ground and paying for
school security but it also may
necessitate the federal government
helping with school repairs that can't
school repairs or the building of a new
school that can't be funded through
other federal accounts like FEMA it's a
it this is not a natural disaster it's a
man-made disaster but like we help
schools that are felled by tornadoes I'm
suggesting we should at least make
eligible for
construction funding schools that are
essentially felled by mass assassins
might I might I ask question also of the
the author of the amendment I ask the
senator is there any language out of
trying to read the amendment I don't see
it any language it says that that that
this this money can only be used where
there's not a applicable FEMA oh well
what a lot what I want to say connection
or were FEMA money may not be quite
enough you use I mean I can see that
there's a difference between a tornado
and earthquakes and fires things like
that where FEMA comes in and provides
money but i think senator said that for
something like that terrible tragedy
newtown that that's not eligible for
FEMA money there's a there's some kind
of a demarcation there and I'm wondering
if if maybe there shouldn't be a some
language there that would say that this
money could be used only if in fact
there's no FEMA money that could be used
or something like that was so so that
kind of separated separates it out for
me from a tornado fires earthquakes
things like that and applies it more to
the kind of tragedies I think bless you
that does that happened in your state
well yeah I'd certainly defer to the
Chairman if that would ultimately you
know win the support of our colleagues
be happy to make that change but again I
don't know that it's necessary given the
fact that the current criteria for
project serve grants just by their very
listing are different incidences than
are eligible for FEMA grants so I think
by virtue of what project serve is
currently currently covers it you
couldn't have FEMA dollars use their
I mean a violent or traumatic crisis as
I understand it is defined in statute
and and and it is clearly not a natural
disaster but I think the definitions in
regulation in regulation I think I got
sure okay well I under FEMA most of the
tornadoes hurricanes floods are covered
by insurance and FEMA only picks up that
part the system didn't have ensured
whereas I don't think insurance covers
any type of act like shooting at Sandy
Hook is that right no I mean the this
municipality essentially is going to
have to pick up the full cost of
building the new school and I was just
informed by my staff that that under the
language of project serve it can't be
used for natural disasters is that right
so I didn't know that I didn't could you
get that language for us before tomorrow
three exactly did I see what senator
Alexander was going to I have me if you
got FEMA money I know that's that's
that's a much bigger pot than what we
have in privatized serve and Senator
Alexander we did look at going that
route essentially changing the FEMA
statute to include school shootings it
seemed to me it seemed to us to be a
much bigger policy change to change the
FEMA statutes then to take a program
that is already funding services at
school shooting sites and make a change
there so we did look at that change it
was a much much bigger change when you
are amending the entirety of FEMA
statutes
for the debate on the amendment again
will not be voting will set this aside
we'll bring it up again tomorrow and if
there's some further debate at that time
we'll we'll debate it further tomorrow
I'll take a closer look at this too
they're just you know I would just say
to my friend from Connecticut that
there's just not that much money in in
in this account it's all well and good i
comes under my Appropriations Committee
I just ask how much money we got there M
gotten very much so I understand what
the senator trying to do I'm very
sympathetic to that but I just think
maybe we can get some get some more
money in their corporations I don't
think so go but anything else so it can
we set will set the stir guide will get
up getting a Miss Shepherd anybody else
has an amendment that wants to offer now
we're you much good tomorrow what system
okay for us mr. members senators who are
here in staff will it will it will
adjourn now and we'll come back together
again tomorrow morning at ten what we'll
do is we'll take up the amendments
hopefully if we have a quorum and we can
move to them and have shortened debate
and a summoning summation by the
Senators who offer those amendments that
will vote on those and then senator
Isakson will be the next one we
recognized yes I thank you all very much
you've been very kind and very generous
for your time to be here today and I
appreciate it well I thank the chairman
for the way he's conducted the hearing
he's given everyone a full chance to
express themselves and they have so
thank you for that I think you're saying
thank you Sarah Alexander okay well we
adjourn till tomorrow morning at ten
o'clock thank you everyone Oh same same
same yeah are we here same room same
room yes here